number three we need people to take it
this vaccine isn't going to help you
if you don't take it and you will need
two doses of this vaccine and most of
the others
to have full protection
watching others take it and hoping that
this will then protect you
isn't going to work necessarily we don't
know if this vaccine will prevent
transmission
or any of them we have to wait for the
science to tell us
if it will prevent transmission though
we are very hopeful on that point
we also have to be patient to see the
real live effects on transmission
and hospitalizations and deaths and
until we see that as scientists
we can't then scope what the likely
impact is going to be
on bringing this pandemic to an
early end and rollout won't be instant
already on the jcvi phase one list
we have around about 30 million
people who are going to be targeted at
some point
and even if you gave me 60 million
vaccines here in this corner now
in a freezer of course but if you gave
me the 60 million
um i couldn't you know no no system in
the world
could distribute those really really
quickly in a matter of a few days
so we have to be realistic about how
long this is going to take it's going to
take months not weeks
and for now the other measures
the tier measures the social distancing
have to stay in place if we relax
too soon if we just kind of go are the
vaccines here
let's abandon caution all you're going
to do
is create a tidal wave of infections
and this vaccine's then got to work in a
headwind
to get back ahead of the game and that
will make it harder
and then the final point is look you
know everyone wants
social distancing to come to an end
we're fed up with it
nobody wants lockdowns and to see the
damage they do
but if you want that dream to come true
as quickly as it can
come true then you have to take the
vaccine
when it's offered to you low uptake
will almost certainly make restrictions
last longer and finally please stick to
the guidance
until we say it is safe to stop